wall in person which is
a novelty at times isn't it
um
you're aware that
we're here just really for for one item
uh it is being streamed
live
so just to be aware of that
so the first
item is attendances
um so you've got some apologies have you
i guess apologies have been received
from council chilton council of western
um
and from council and military
right okay
it was yeah is that better yes sorry i
did press it but it didn't
it obviously didn't come on
um
yeah i mean the council called of
conduct we are required um as a scrutiny
committee to approve
the
code of cont
recommendations it has actually been
approved
at standards committee
and it's been to the constitution
panel uh and
ultimately it'll be
it will go to
the executive and then the full council
to
agree
uh or otherwise
um so
we we
um are required i think by law isn't it
to
to uh agree
or otherwise um the code of conduct
and we've got a report
there
and really
you know it is on for discussion i hope
everybody's had chance to
read it
and understand it
are there any comments
from members
yeah
yeah
yeah
that's what i yeah that's what i was
saying you know everybody's
read it
um
and
we can have a discussion now
around the
content
uh whether you know
it's
recommendations from this
from members whether they want to
make changes to what's been uh forwarded
to us so yeah
jed
thank you chad um
this is probably one of the last times
i'll say this but there's somebody's in
a first year
um
on scrutiny this is the first time i've
um
been asked to look at this document just
as an observation that might be a couple
of points to come out after this but as
an observation when i was reading
through this um
last week i was kind of expecting to see
something explicitly in it about
an expectation that councillors will
speak truthfully and not deceitfully and
that be one of the key points in here
and there's about eight or nine things
that ten things eleven
ten things i think that are
what we are saying we will hold
ourselves and our colleagues um to
accounts on and none of them start off
with being truthful and
honest and not deceiving
within the report that the general
principles are set out
and that is act with integrity and
honesty
act lawfully
treat all
persons fairly and with respect
and lead by example and act in a way
that uh secures public confidence in the
role of counsellor
he does actually in there
i knew it was in there within the bones
and with the appendices it's just an
observation if we're listing out ten
things that we expect to hold people to
account for one of them being
honestly and truthfulness i personally
anticipated would have been
thanks chair um good evening everybody
um just just to add some context um in
terms of the report that's before you
today
just to stress that we have been through
an extensive consultation exercise we
have consulted widely with members and
whilst we welcome an open discussion and
i'm happy to take conversation questions
and clarify anything um that's
outstanding tonight it isn't for debate
in terms of further amendments
we've already had that opportunity so
just wanted to clarify that chair
i think jets point is an interesting one
i think all of us just anticipate that
uses words like integrity and um
preserving the
reputation of the council
i think we all eschew or we did assume
that that means not that means being
honest and not telling
birth-based lies i suspect the question
comes from the events of recent times in
central government
where it appears to be that um it
appears to be that
unless unless something is specifically
forbidden
then people feel
uh
empowered to do it
would that be fair jedi you were shaking
your head when i was talking
wasn't specifically to do with central
government i could think of examples of
um
outside or traffic but closer to home um
so i might come back to that later if i
might share but just come back to
yourself i don't recall
as a member being offered consultation
opportunity on this but
we get a blizzard of emails every day so
i might try to miss that
um just to confirm it was we were sent
out through leaders of each party and
everybody was invited to submit comments
back
the journey of this code started in
trafford 2021
to gather pace in terms of our internal
consultation exercise of course it's
been knocking around for 12 months prior
to that and so
um we did receive a range
of responses through the consultation
exercise and we did we went out to
parish councillors as well and uh
independent people
and so we did consult on a wider basis
and and that was the opportunity for all
members to contribute to that
yeah i mean i i wasn't aware of
that and i'm the chair of this committee
so
um
i i just wonder
how how
and why that is the case um maybe i've
i've just missed it but i
i don't recall
anybody speaking to me i know i've been
i've been on the constitution
uh panel so i i am aware of it and uh
and we had a discussion about it
um i wasn't aware
particularly that
this committee couldn't make amendments
to it if we so wished
to
now that you know that that wouldn't be
the end of the game it would be a
recommendation so i don't know whether
that is the case
or not but i wasn't told that that was
the case otherwise
there's hardly any reason for us to meet
if we can't
at least
say you know
have a debate around that and uh
if you have a debate and you can't make
a recommendation it's not what's put
into the debate
um so that that's just my my view on
that
yeah
jill
yeah i think i think that's no issues
really nothing to discuss about it i
think it looks really good to me um the
process as you say is a little bit
unclear in terms of if we're just
approving it and why would we be
improving it because we're not generally
proof stuff do we generally scrutinize
but the thing is just a little bit
detail in the in the amendments because
a little bit confused about amendment
number eight
where it says
there is
replace the word protecting with
preserving but it's actually just got up
holding in the thingy so i wasn't was a
bit confused about the suggested
amendments the amendments proposed on
page four
um
it says um
the wording was amended to replace the
word protecting the word preserving
i don't know i just didn't understand
why i couldn't see the word
i didn't understand the amendments
because if they're not in the document i
didn't know why
and also on um appendix b72 the world
authority i didn't understand that
amendment but they're just like you know
pinnickety points
sorry
so that particular amendment in terms of
the wording of protecting and preserving
came from standards committee and
feedback from there um and that was
particularly around
how how the standards committee thought
that word portrayed
and the word um protecting almost they
felt um
was counterproductive and and suggested
actually that they had something to
protect so i really should be preserving
or something different so we we had
those discussions and moved that
amendment along really um
and that's been picked up in the in the
proposed code going forward
okay so it's been changed up holding
which is it sounds like a good one good
word to use is that correct yeah on page
13.
it's just i didn't understand the
purpose of the amendments if they
weren't included in the document so i
mean they seem to be generally
but i was just being penicus i do
apologize
well only to comment that it seems to me
that the scrutiny committee had a
dictionary they wouldn't have to be so
predictive that's protected perfectly
adequate to me it's not uh
it doesn't suggest anything negative to
might to my mind so it just seems
um that perhaps you could look to all
definitions of the word rather than
squeezing an amendment and i didn't know
there was a committee that was
pinnicketier than all the nurses
of course the scrutiny committee is
entitled to to raise any concerns and
we'll have to take that away but what
that would do is send the whole thing
back in terms of the process and we'd
have to then go back and change the code
and then go take it back to standards
and then bring it back to scrutiny then
to get it onto executive
um the the approach that we took
um was agreed by the standards committee
in terms of let's do a consultation more
widely and let's take that feedback
through that process so that once we had
taken that feedback we'd be able to
present it to both standards
constitutional working group and then
yourselves before then asking for a
recommendation onto full council for
adoption and so that was the route that
we took um
and because we took that route that's
why i'm sat here saying that that
process has been undertaken
so at this stage in the process we
should be just looking at approving it
because we've been through the
consultation process of course if you
have major concerns then we will take
that on board absolutely and we'll take
that away but you have to be aware that
we then would have to go back through
the process and this was unlikely to
meet the may council meeting
i wasn't aware that that's the way that
the process
was working quite frankly i thought that
we could actually make recommendations
if we felt i mean personally i'm
absolutely fine with it i think
i have no problems whatsoever row as you
would just once
thank you i have absolutely no major
concerns about it i think on the whole
it's
well written well updated and i'm very
happy with it yeah thank you i am sorry
yeah
yeah i concur with that i don't have any
issues with it at all i do have a slight
issue and perhaps um alex you could ask
for some um clarification on this going
forward about things being passed in
front of scrutiny with no expectation of
discussion or ability to change because
that's not what i understand our role to
be our role is not as i understand it to
nod at things
um but i am absolutely perfectly happy
with what i see um and wouldn't even if
we had the ability to have recommended
any particular changes so it's fine by
me
i think i'll
conquer it's um it's it's i ain't got
any problems um fundamentally with the
um
proposal maybe we might um have an
opportunity to use this time as we're
all gathered here to to agree
on some educational examples
so
if somebody if a member
say i'm trying to use examples outside
of traffic if a member um said oh you
don't want to vote for that like you
want to work with this lot because
they're going to close the hospital and
that was unfounded would that be an
example of
something that would breach the code
uh or or on the other side of that
equation if somebody said well if you
vote for us we'll build 42 new hospitals
and that wasn't
technically the case would that also be
a breach of the code
yeah i'll leave that to the leader
i'm going to answer that with a very
vague answer um what i would suggest is
in terms of practical examples
the lda have
put out a guidance document and in that
contains a lot of practical examples and
that's meant to be read as an aid to
this code so read that alongside this
particularly in relation to um
declarations of interest and so forth
there's a there's a flowchart that helps
you navigate that
so that's one recommendation in terms of
your specific question
does such a scenario breach the code um
what we'd have to do is look at the
circumstances in every single case and
and that's a a scale for the monitoring
officer to to consider and it and you
know
you wouldn't be able to say yes a
blanket yes that would breach the code
because you have to look at all the
examples and all the circumstances of
that situation before you'd be able to
make that determination but in terms of
practical examples practical application
of the code itself look to the guidance
document is really helpful
yeah i mean i think
it's how it's said isn't it as well it's
it's the words that you use
you know it seems to me that
you know
that hospital is going to be closed
that wouldn't be a lie would it it would
be it would be an assumption on that
person
but
and we could argue for uh forever more
on that yeah dylan
uh
[Music]
i've got some points to raise about i'm
not saying i want to see any critical of
the code of conduct it's in itself per
se but
some points that have come up recently
anyway and i do understand the
monitoring officer has the statute of
responsibility for the implementation of
the code of conduct yeah
uh i mean the member's code of conduct
you know i
believe applies where the interface is
in three areas
of activity which i mean one would be
regarded as with the public
media
another one would be personal interest
conflict of interest things like that
and the other one
i believe is in
when members
uh in full council
committees
so are you interfacing with members and
executive
and it can't be con i don't think the
code of conduct can be considered in
isolation in some cases such as in
meeting the full council or with the
staff executive
uh i mean the module officer should have
if not already within his or her terms
of reference to exercise the right i
think to intervene when a member or
senior politician remember the senior
political position
is allowed to make responses considered
as personal attacks
or of a bullying nature
uh and is not subject to intervention by
a mayor be for you know a personal
reason uh
that mo i mean that moment is an
important juncture where the monitoring
officer should recognize and take the
initiative and intervene because it can
prevent such a situation unnecessarily
escalating into a code of conduct issue
further to that you know the any person
in a senior political position should
not be seated
well
i would say that like for example the
leader to next to a monitoring officer
where you see has the ability to
to apply perceived subtle pressure
during an issue that arises in the
meeting
some of these points link with committee
rules and the monitoring conferences
terms of reference
so i think for the benefit of all
members in order to avoid matters in
council escalating to position where it
could possibly breach be a breach of
conduct
the points i have raised should be
addressed with a review of those
procedures as well so you know it seems
to have
interfaces
that uh that need to be looked at as
well which are for the benefit of
members in a way because it
it can avoid
circumstances getting out of our funding
away
thank you
i think there's a a few points there um
that i'd just like to come back on it
one in terms of um meetings you you
refer to council meetings um
the chair is
is is in charge of that meeting and so
um
in some instances it may be
inappropriate for the munching officer
to step forward i think the other thing
i would say also is that one thing that
the code is missing and has always been
missing is any sanctions
um so it tells us what um what would uh
be acceptable in terms of code of
conduct british doesn't then tell us
what the monetary officer can do about
that
and that's something that's been absent
from the code
for
you know
for a long time
and it is something that keeps coming
back in terms of uh
the request to add something in there
to to actually set out
with more
certainty around where the munching
officer could step in and what then
their sanction could be
that sanction and that approach is not
reflected in legislation and therefore
it's not reflected within the code of
conduct and that's across the board
that's not just in trafford that's
across the board
um
and there has been several uh
particularly in relation to this model
code and there has been several calls
for further clarification there and
strengthening if you like of the
monetary officer's position in that
respect
and also to provide members with more
certainty around what that
those sanctions might be but it's not
yet there yet
and um
for example chief legal officers of uh
gm have been calling for that
um but it's still not there and so we
have to wait for that to be embedded or
enshrined with legislation before we can
pull that through and until we do that
i guess the other side of that argument
is
whilst it's not prescribed in there
there's a little bit more flexibility
in terms of approaching different
scenarios based on the the context and
circumstances and then the munching
office is really using their discretion
in terms of how they deal with that
does that answer your question
[Music]
well i think well i think it it has been
answered i think it is up to the chair
really to
to step in if that hits the
feeling of the chair
and i think there is opportunities or
not to refer
members to the standards committee
when
um when there's conflict with
uh the the
um
the policies the code of conduct so
yeah kevin yeah can you just make a
few comments really um
in terms of the guidance this is the
model code and i think it's it's really
good it's basically most people are
using it most local authorities but it
can't meet every single circumstance
you know so life is so complicated isn't
it that it it could never ever meet
every single circumstance that
you know comes we've come across but i
think it's pretty good in terms of that
um
and you know that's one of the reasons
why we're pretty much adopting it as it
as it is uh set out um just going back a
bit as well um
members did get an opportunity to
comment on this
i mean it was was discussed
standards committee but it was all other
members were also given the opportunity
and i don't think we actually got many
responses back from members on that so
it was missed by many many people
and which you know the amount of
millionaires you do get that's not not
surprising really so you know that there
were opportunities there prior to it
getting to this point this point in the
in the process
um and maybe it's a learning thing
israel i therefore i i i think
as jed he said we we we do get
millions of
uh emails and some you
you know you look at intently and some
of you
they go past you quite frankly and this
this might have been rather
yeah
just to add that being i very much
appreciate the opportunity to comment as
an individual member but i think that's
different to being
asked to
um look at it at scrutiny committee i
think the two things um
are
distinct and
have different purposes within the realm
of the council so being asked to
contribute with an individual is one
thing
being asked to
look at something that's greeting
committee is to me anywhere my
understanding is slightly different and
that our role is different to having an
individual an individual opinion just
just to make that so i do appreciate
what you're saying very much but i still
a little bit curious as to why we're
sitting here tonight other than the fact
that i know
by regulation it has to come through
scrutiny committee
again just to reiterate not because i
would like to make any changes or
anything i'm quite happy with it i'm
just a bit concerned about not concerned
confused as always by the procedural
aspects of that
okay well i think
uh judging by the discussion we've had
i think there's
a
general agreement in the
um
you know in the recommendations to adopt
uh
the council code have come up
and then it will go to the executive so
is everybody happy to agree the
recommendations yeah
okay well
that concludes the meeting and thank you
very much for your attendance